Aquí escribí algunas algunos ejemplos de relaciones
entre dos variables en este caso tenemos
"m" y "n",
"a" y "b",
"x" y "y"
y quiero a ver si podemos identificar
si las relaciones son directas,
es decir,
si varían directamente o
varían inversamente
o tal vez ninguna de las dos.
Así que iniciemos con esto, aquí tengo yo,
"m" sobre "n" es igual a 1 sobre 7.
Vamos a manipular esto,
si multiplicamos ambos lados por "n", ¿qué obtenemos?
Lo que tú quieres en general hacer,
es separar las variables,
que una te queda de un lado y la otra del otro,
para ver a qué forma llegas,
si a la forma, "m" es igual a "k" por "n",
eso sería variación directa,
o a la forma "m" igual a "k" por 1 sobre "n",
eso es variación inversa.
¿Cuál de estas dos variaciones será?
Así que tenemos esta primera relación,
vamos a multiplicar ambos lados de la relación
o de la ecuación por "n".
y tenemos entonces que "m" es igual,
estos dos se cancelan,
"m" es igual a 1 sobre 7 por "n".
Y puedes ver que tiene la misma forma
de la variación directa, cierto,
estamos aquí,
"m" es igual a una constante multiplicada por "n",
así que esto,
es variación directa,
están variando directamente,
es variación directa.
Ahora, vamos con la siguiente,
"a" por "b" es igual a -3,
aquí podemos dividir entre "a" o entre "b", no importa, pero vamos a dividir entre "a"
a así que
"a" por "b" entre "a"
es igual a -3 entre "a",
se cancelan las aes
y nos queda "b" igual a -3 entre "a"
y eso es lo mismo que,
"b" igual a -3 por 1 sobre "a"
esto tiene la misma forma que esta variación,
la variación inversa, cierto,
aquí el -3 es la constante,
es "k"
así que esto es,
variación inversa,
variación inversa...
Ahora,
vamos con la siguiente, tenemos,
"x" por "y" es igual a 1 sobre 10,
aquí otra vez vamos a separar las variables,
entonces voy a dividir entre alguna de las dos,
ya sea entre "x" o entre "y",
elijo a "x",
porque solo hay que dividir entre alguna de las dos.
Entonces,
aquí dividido entre "x",
aquí se cancelan las "x",
nos queda "y" es igual a 1 sobre 10 sobre "x",
lo cual es lo mismo que 1 sobre "10x"
y esto es igual a 1 sobre 10
multiplicado por 1 sobre "x",
esto es la constante,
esto es que "k" multiplicado por 1 sobre "x",
así que esto es variación inversa,
ahora vamos con la siguiente.
Bueno de hecho ya está esa... esa ya está...
es un regalo de... el regalo del día,
porque ve aquí tenemos
simplemente hay que voltear la igualdad,
ponemos entonces,
a "n"...
ajá, ok,
"n" es igual a 9 por 1 sobre "m",
y ya tiene la forma de variación inversa,
y tenemos la constante
9 multiplicado a  1 sobre "m",
ajá, entonces tienen la forma de variación inversa.
¡Ay! también recuerda,
aquí "n" está variando inversamente con "m"
lo cual es lo mismo que "m" varía inversamente con "n",
son equivalentes.
Ahora vamos con este,
tenemos "b" es igual a un tercio menos "a"
y aquí hay un truco, cierto,
aquí no está muy claro,
tenemos aquí una constante,
de hecho,
ya están las variables separadas
pero tenemos ahí un signo menos, en sí...
no sabemos si es variación...
variación directa o variación inversa,
y de hecho, oh sorpresa,
es ninguna de las dos,
no es ni variación directa,
ni variación inversa.
Entonces, ok, variación directa,
si la variable "x" aquí tenemos "x" y "y"
entonces,
si la variable "x" se incrementa,
en su escala, digamos por 2,
de 1 a 2,
también la variable "y"
incrementaría en la misma escala,
o mejor voy a poner a "m" y a "n",
porque son las que voy a usar para este ejemplo,
entonces, digamos,
si "n" es igual a...
tenemos "m" es igual a
1 sobre 7 por "n"
si "n" es igual a 1,
entonces "m" es igual a 1 sobre 7,
ajá...
ahora cuando "n" es igual a 7,
"m" es igual a 1,
y puedes ver que "n" crece en escala de 7.
Si eso pasa también,
"m" está creciendo en una escala de 7, cierto,
lo podemos ver aquí en la tabla entonces...
están variando directamente, cuando "m" crece "n" crece,
cuando "n" crece "m" crece,
así que esto...
esto es variación directa...
esto es variación directa.
Ahora vamos con este otro ejemplo,
de variación inversa,
entonces voy a poner las variables en la tabla,
tenemos...
tenemos "a" y "b".
Cuando "a" es igual a 1,
podemos ver que "b" es igual a -3, cierto,
simplemente vamos a poner aquí,
1 sobre 1 se cancela y nos queda,
"b" es igual a -3 sobre 1, es igual a -3,
ahora cuando "a" es igual a 3,
cuando multiplicamos esto por 3,
entonces ¿qué pasa?
vamos a obtener "b" igual a -1, cierto,
ahora, nota que aquí yo no estoy multiplicando por 3, estoy dividiendo entre 3,
o lo que es lo mismo,
estoy multiplicando,
estoy multiplicando, pero por el inverso de 3,
por 1 sobre 3
así que,
si yo aquí estoy incrementando la escala de 1 a 3,
del lado de "b" está...
está decreciendo, cierto,
en este otro caso,
de ninguno, verás que ninguno de los dos se cumplen,
ni el directo, ni el inverso.
Así que, ok, en este otro tenemos aquí,
"a" y "b",
cuando "a" es igual a 1,
veamos qué sucede,
tenemos un tercio menos 1, eso sería igual
a menos dos tercios, ajá,
y ok, si aquí dividimos entre 3,
sólo por diversión,
tendríamos entonces...
tendríamos entonces "a" igual a un tercio,
o es lo mismo que multiplicar por un tercio,
entonces si "a" es igual a un tercio,
"b" es igual a 0,
y aquí no está algo extraño,
si esto fuera una varia...
si esto fuera variación directa,
estaríamos multiplicando por un tercio,
lo cual no hicimos
y si fuera variación inversa,
estaríamos multiplicando por 3
lo cual tampoco pasó.
Entonces,
aquí los factores no alteraron en realidad esto,
cierto,
esto simplemente
fue una traslación de dos tercios.
las variables en esta último...
las variables en este último ejemplo,
no están variando ni inversamente ni directamente.